okay guys i'm here with Hikaru Nakamura
so you just played a blitz rapid and
Fisher random match against fabiano
caruana did that and add any kind of
dynamic to this game not particularly
maybe the only thing it at is that I
didn't want to do something really
stupid and just make a really bad boner
like I did one of the rapid games um and
that may be affected my judgment because
basically I spent all my time
calculating a certain wine and then I
decided to play just a bad move instead
and after that it was just something
much worse not losing I was a little bit
well I'm not a little bit i was a very
fortunate to fabiano played Queen c2
along this Queen Queen trade um it's
probably so objectively winning somehow
but it becomes a really difficult
technical task whereas if fabiano put
rook on c1 like workup c1 or something i
saw this queens to move i mean i should
just be winning i don't think it's even
gonna be close it's just probably over
but I mean fabiano I think just
underestimated this clean exchange I
think he thought that pretty much
anything was winning and well it
probably is still winning it's just a
very difficult and I found a way to put
up the most resistance and I was able to
draw the game a lot of people say that
you should always fight never give up in
chess but do you have any practical
advice or people when you're in a bad
position fabiano pleased your defensive
skills today I think I think in general
just try and find the best moves I mean
I pretty much knew that it was going to
be a very difficult if not losing so I
kind of just try to take it one move at
a time and that's really the only thing
you can do when you have a really bad
position just play one move at a time
tried to find the best move and just
just keep going and maybe things will go
things will go your way and don't get
too emotional about it oh yes
not what I did so if you had to play a
tournament where you play the same
opening with white or black against
these guys which opening do you think
would give you the biggest edge probably
anything except the Berlin anything but
we'll pick one I don't have 1 i'm just
going to say that I prefer anything but
the Berlin with white or black but
that's the way modern trusses all right
well not loving the Berlin so much today
but it's gave me with a draw we have
Nakamura our number one us player in the
US Champion